here are the five strongest quirks in  mha overhaul gives its user the ability  to disassemble and then reassemble  matter he can destroy matter restore it  into its original state or reassemble  the matter into something new Decay  allows its user to destroy anything or  anyone that he touches after The Quirk  awakens it can destroy a huge section of  an entire city in seconds New Order  allows its user to rewrite the rules of  physics by touching something and saying  its name she can bestow new rules and  properties onto herself and the world  around her all for one allows its user  to steal multiple quirks from others and  either use them or transfer them to  someone else finally pop-off allows its  user to produce sticky purple balls from  his head okay I'm kidding the final  Quirk is one for all for a full video  about one for all click the link in the  description